- I'm Nikki Glaser and
this is Even Not Safer.
Tonight I'm here with
"At Midnight" host
Chris Hardwick and
"At Midnight" regular,
Jen Kirkman.
(applause)
You know, you can find
anything on Craigslist;
a used futon, a used
roommate, or a casual
encounter with a totally
shaved Eastern European.
(laughter)
There's something for
everyone, so this is
"Gross Encounters of
the Craigslist Kind."
(applause)
Here's how it's going to work.
I'm gonna show you
guys three nasty
casual encounters
that I personally
posted on Craigslist
myself, and then
I want you to guess
which one of those
posts got a response
from someone.
Onl one of them did, alright.
So the first one,
the subject was
"Only ball play - nothing else."
I am very attractive
single woman
in her 50's looking
for a man who is
willing to letting me
play with only his balls.
Nothing else! No
kissing! No dick!
No butt! No dinner! Camera okay!
I can come to you between
three and five PM.
Thanks and have a great day.
(applause)
That's number one.
Okay, here's the next one.
Please be my sex robot!
Looking for a man to come over
and be my sex robot.
Must wear silver gray,
preferably shiny clothing.
I will program you for
cleaning, fucking, etcetera.
I will name you either
your name plus 3000
and or Robo plus your name and
you will call me Master.
Must be able to do
realistic sounding
robot voice and
also deep throat.
(laughing)
Reasonable request.
(appause)
Okay, and here's the last one.
Reliable chub seeks
thick foreskin.
No nonsense chub looking for
fit stranger with
thick foreskin.
If it don't stretch like taffy,
move along, little doggie.
I'll leave the door
unlocked and will
be already nude
listening to NPR.
I am clean. You be, too.
If we hit it off, you can take
some of my bison
chili for the road.
No condoms!
(groaning)
(applause)
That's a nice offer.
So, those are the
three, you guys.
- [Jen] Okay...
- For Craigslist,
I feel like these
aren't even that
far out of bounds.
- [Nikki] No, they're not!
- I'm gonna guess only ball play
because I think there's
something about...
I like the three to
five if you're married,
"Honey, I'm just gonna
pick up the kids."
And then you go do
that real quick first.
- Yeah!
- I think the guy
wants only ball play.
- [Chris] I think sex
robot, because I know
there's a dude out
there who immediately
saw that and was like, "I
will send you my digits."
"01101101111..."
I feel like it's
gotta be sex robot,
but they're all
really believable.
- They're all enticing.
- Yeah, we got
taken off Craigslist
so much before we aced these.
(laughter)
Like we got flagged.
- What do you have to do to get
taken off of Craigslist?
- Oh, just poop
stuff, mostly. So...
(laughter)
- I regret to inform you
that both of you are wrong,
the real thing that
got a response was
"Reliable Chub Seeks
Thick Foreskin."
(applause)
- Oh my god, the word
reliable is so like,
"Well, this old chub
sure is reliable."
(laughing)
- And it's what you say in a lie
about a car before it's about to
break down when
you're selling it.
- The response that
he wrote back was,
I would love Chris if
you would read it for us.
- Sure, I'd love to.
Subject line, "Hey Stetcher."
I am six-two, 205 pounds,
mine does stretch,
I don't know how much.
I put two fingers on the head
and then rolled it over them.
May I come over?
I'm very clean and
will shave first.
Douglas.
(laughing)
(applause)
- [Nikki] I love that
his name is Douglas.
(applause)
- Oh, Douglas!
Give it up one more
time for my friends,
Jen Kirkman and Christ Hardwick.
See you next time on Not Safer.
(applause)